die gefundenen überreste einer vom krieg
erschütterten anlage in den bergen es
sieht so seltsam aus sie verliert sich
einfach in den wäldern
ein geheimnisvoller militär einsam in
eisigen gewässern
ein wirklich mysteriöser ort was könnte
das gewesen sein
dass auf grund gelaufene rostige wrack
eines längst verlassenen schiffes
[Applaus]
es hat etwas gruseliges an sich man
fragt sich was dahinter steckt und
eine marode brücke im südlichsten
bundesstaat der usa
sie scheint mir uns hinzuführen es steht
nichts darauf was war also ihr zweck
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauwerten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
diese anlagen aufgegeben manche sind
heute lebensgefährlich verseucht aber
wer hat sie erschaffen und wie und warum
wurden sie wieder aufgegeben
[Musik]
in bosnien in den bergen um sarajevo
steht eine rätselhafte verlassener
anlage
[Musik]
entlang eines bergs windet sich ein
geflecht schneebedeckter betonmauern
brücken und kanäle
[Musik]
die anlage sieht echt seltsam aus diese
gefundenen leichen aufbauten die aus der
wand hoch ragen das ganze scheint sich
fast in den wäldern zu verlieren
es sieht aus wie aus mad max ein
austragungsort für futuristische todes
spiele
durch die wälder hoch über der stadt
schlängelt sich einen beton kanal
verfällt langsam ist voller graffiti von
moos bewachsen ein sehr seltsamer ort
und es ist nicht die einzige verlassener
anlage hier an den berghängen rund um
die stadt stehen weitere verfallene
bauten gemeinsam erzählen sie eine
düstere geschichte die jahrzehnte
zurückreicht aber wofür wurden sie einst
berichtet und warum sind sie heute
verwahrlost und verlassen ein
[Musik]
teil der antwort hängt mit der
zerstörerischen schlacht um sarajevo
während des bosnienkriegs zusammen die
belagerung von sarajevo der hauptstadt
bosniens und herzegowinas
wurde zum blutigen symbol des konflikts
sie begannen im april 1992 als 13.000
bosnisch serbische soldaten die stadt
einkesselten und endete erst nach fast
vier jahren damit dauerte sie deutlich
länger als die belagerungen star in graz
und leningrad während des zweiten
weltkriegs
[Musik]
was hier geschah war düstere schatten
über das land und machte männer wie
stanislaw gutsch und agonie milosevic
weltweit berüchtigt
[Musik]
waren die bauten teil eines
militärkomplexes
auf den ersten blick ähneln sie
tatsächlich einer sturmreif geschossen
verteidigungsanlage
[Musik]
das ist eine strategisch wichtige lage
denn typischerweise hat die
konfliktparteien mit der höher gelegenen
position einen vorteil von hier aus
konnte man mit artillerie und
heckenschützen die stadt terrorisiert
die heckenschützen zählten damals auf
jeden sie erschossen nicht nur soldaten
sondern auch zivilisten kinder jeden der
eben ins kreuzfeuer geriet es war
grausam
aber die anlagen waren nicht für den
krieg gebaut worden
sie waren teil eines der stolzesten
ereignisse in der geschichte der stadt
es sind die überreste vom
austragungsstätten der olympischen
winterspiele
die winterspiele waren sehr bedeutsam
für sarajevo es war das erste mal dass
in einem sozialistischen staat
ausgetragen wurden und für jugoslawien
waren sie die chance sich der welt im
besten licht zu präsentieren
sarajevo in den fokus der
weltöffentlichkeit und man hofft dass
sich das für den tourismus in
jugoslawien positiv auswirkt
aber wie bei vielen anderen und
inzwischen spielen liefen die kosten für
den bau von infrastruktur und
sportstätten völlig aus dem ruder
[Musik]
auch die verfallenden bauten hier sehen
er nach verzweiflung als nach
feierlichkeit aus
[Musik]
der lange sarajevo die spiele zu einem
erfolg zu machen
man muss den sportlern und allen die
herkommen um die spiele zu sehen etwas
bieten da gab es viel zu tun
in die sportstätten selbst und in die
infrastruktur um mit den menschenmassen
fertig zu werden eine enorme aufgabe hat
eine der wichtigsten austragungsstätten
war dieser gefundene beton kanal
seine lage am berghang lässt schon
erahnen worum es sich dabei handelt eine
bob und rodelbahn
slavko maria hat damals eine der
olympischen austragungsstätten verwaltet
[Musik]
sie ist eine der steilsten bahnen der
welt die bobs erreichen hier sehr hohe
geschwindigkeiten und die fahrer mussten
aufpassen nicht umzukippen aber obwohl
sie so schnell und so steil bargeld die
bahn als eine der sichersten
heute erzählen die verfallenden
löchrigen überreste auch von ihrem
späteren schicksal aber waren die bahn
und die anderen anlagen amberg teil
einer olympischen erfolgsgeschichte am 8
februar 1984 blickte die welt nach
sarajevo
[Musik]
die winterspiele waren nicht nur
technisch und organisatorisch betrachtet
ein erfolg sondern auch finanziell ein
plus von umgerechnet 20 millionen dollar
spricht wohl für sich ich wüsste nicht
dass olympische spiele je so ein erfolg
waren vor allem nicht mehr heutzutage
es waren die ersten winterspiele seit
anfang der 1930 er jahre die geld
einbrachten für jugoslawien ein großer
erfolg
nach dem winter spielen wurden die
anlagen weiter genutzt auf der rodelbahn
wurden weltmeisterschaften ausgetragen
und das skigebiet war eins der
beliebtesten im laden
heute ist unübersehbar dass der
olympische traum schließlich ausgeträumt
war
was also ist geschehen
[Musik]
ich hätte nie gedacht dass es in
sarajevo krieg geben könnte nicht eine
sekunde lang hätte ich mir das
vorstellen können die bewohner der stadt
sahen diesen krieg nicht kommen
nur acht jahre nach den spielen 1992
zerbrach die sozialistische republik
jugoslawien
und sarajevo wurde zu einem schlachtfeld
des bosnienkriegs
fast vier jahre anhaltende kämpfe
zwischen der muslimischen serbischen und
kroatischen bevölkerung bosniens
zerrissen die region die bosnischen
serben hatten die stadt fest im griff
und belagerten sie 44 monate lang die
längste belagerung einer hauptstadt in
der neueren geschichte
der von löchern durchsiebte beton der
bauten erzählt bis heute vom krieg und
der berghang an dem die rodelbahn steht
spielte darin eine düstere rolle
die bobbahn bei eine zeitlang die
frontlinie zwischen den kriegsparteien
unglücklicherweise wurde die bahn durch
granatwerfer beschädigt und noch dazu
als artilleriestellung benutzt alle
anlagen in der nähe wurden zerstört
wegen ihrer erhöhten lagen über der
stadt wurden dieser und andere berghänge
rundum sarajevo zu wichtigen angriff
stellungen von denen aus die
bosnisch-serbische artillerie die stadt
unter dauerbeschuss namen
auf dem höhepunkt der belagerung gingen
täglich 300 granaten auf sarajevo nieder
der bosnisch-serbische befehlshaber
sagte bordt sie in den wahnsinn und das
taten sie
erinnerungen an die große geschichte der
stadt verblassten neben berichten
furchtbarer gräueltaten
am siegertreppchen spielten sich einige
der schlimmsten ereignisse ab soldaten
nahmen bewohner der stadt gefangen
brachten sie zum siegertreppchen und
richteten sie dorthin
das einstige olympische hotel wurden als
gefängnis genutzt
während der belagerung starben so viele
tausend menschen dass der platz ausging
um sie zu begraben so wurde schließlich
das olympiastadion zum friedhof
umfunktioniert
am 29 februar 1996 hatte das martyrium
endlich ein ende aber bis es soweit war
hatten bereits mehr als 11.000 einwohner
sarajevos ihr leben gelassen
[Musik]
in der stadt wurde inzwischen einiges
wieder aufgebaut aber die verlassenen
anlagen an diesem werk erinnern bis
heute an das wohl dunkelste kapitel in
der geschichte sarajevos
[Musik]
die überreste dieser winterspiele
sollten uns ein andenken an den geist
und die errungenschaften jugoslawiens
seien
nicht an die grauenvollen dinge die sich
hier später abspielten
[Musik]
160 kilometer südwestlich von marie
steht ein riesiges verlassenes bauwerk
zwischen den florida keys erstreckt sich
diese und anderthalb kilometer lange
brücke
wie eine riesige um gefallene star
konstruktion
ein beeindruckender bau aus stahl und
beton
mittendrin klafft eine große lücke
eine kleinere gibt es am südlichen ende
da sind die sie scheint nirgends hin zu
führen es steht nichts darauf was war
also hier zweck
ein rostiges rohr verläuft entlang der
unteren ebene durch eine verschachtelte
metallstruktur
darüber bilden rissige betonplatten eine
ehemalige fahrbahn hat der standort der
brücke etwas mit ihrem schlechten
zustand zu tun
[Musik]
die florida keys liegen mitten im
hurrikan gebiet süd florida wird am
häufigsten getroffen
aber was war der zweck dieser riesigen
brücke warum wurde sie hier erbaut und
warum wurde sie sich selbst und dem meer
überlassen
[Musik]
ein teil ihrer geschichte ist mit einem
ort in mittelamerika verbunden gut 1600
kilometer entfernt hier wurde um den
beginn des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
eines der ehrgeizigsten bauprojekte
aller zeiten umgesetzt der panamakanal
schiffe können seitdem vom pazifik in
den atlantik oder in die andere richtung
fahren ohne tausende kilometer umweg um
kap horn machen zu müssen es war eine
revolution des frachtverkehrs
die 82 kilometer lange künstliche
wasserstraße sollte pazifik und atlantik
verbindet und den frachtverkehr so
einfacher und schneller machen
die arbeiten hatten bereits 1881
begonnen aber der bau war zu schwierig
und riskant
1904 übernahmen schließlich den usa die
kontrolle über das bauprojekt und 1914
konnte der kanal eröffnet werden
jetzt rückte plötzlich key west in den
fokus als südlichste punkt der
kontinentalen usa war die inselstadt
perfekt geeignet für die schiffe das tor
zu den vereinigten staaten zu werden
aber der us bundesstaat florida war
darauf nicht vorbereitet
die west war eine florierende hafenstadt
eine der größten städte in ganz florida
interessanterweise war aber der rest von
florida damals noch kaum entwickelt es
bestand größtenteils aus unbewohntem
buschland und sümpfen die ferienorte und
städte und disney world das alles gab es
noch nicht
das hauptproblem war dass key west keine
straßenverbindung zum festland hatte und
der stadt plante auch nicht eine zu
bauen wer also errichtete die brücke und
warum
park ranger eleison weiß darüber
bescheid
ein mann namens henry morrison flegler
beschloss die brücke zu bauen er hatte
bereits mit dem bau der eisenbahnstrecke
entlang der ostküste bis nach miami
begonnen und entschied die strecke nach
keywords zu verlängern er ging es also
an
die brücken überspannte einmal die
türkischen gewässer die die bahnstrecke
klären musste es ist die bar honda
bridge
das war eine der technisch schwierigsten
aufgaben des gesamten bauprojekt weil
das wasser relativ tief ist es ist nicht
so leicht dort zu bauen
damals war sie eine echte technische
innovation und heute 100 jahre später
steht sie noch immer
aber diese brücke war nur eine von
vielen die gesamte strecke sollte über
200 kilometer von key west bis aufs
festland führen
[Musik]
es war ein ehrgeiziges projekt wenn man
sich mal die karte anguckt sieht man
dass die strecke fast genauso weit über
das wasser zwischen den inseln führt wie
über die inseln
das hieß also brücken über rund 40
verschiedene wasser abschnitte zu bauen
1905 begannen die arbeiten an der
bahnstrecke der so genannten over the
world
um ein erfolg zu werden musste sie vor
der eröffnung des panama-kanals fertig
sein und falls es nicht gelingen die
gewässer um bei 400 zu klären war das
ganze projekt gescheitert
die bei 400 bridge war der schwierigste
abschnitt für die arbeiter sie ist
anderthalb kilometer lang der kanal ist
mit etwa neun metern der tiefste
zwischen den kies die strömung ist stark
und es gibt jeden tag vier
gezeitenwechsel
[Musik]
und auch das manchmal extreme tropische
wetter machte sich bald bemerkbar
einige schwierigkeiten in den kies sind
die hurricanes heute wissen wir eine
woche im voraus wenn einer kommt aber
damals kamen sie wie aus dem nichts es
gab noch keine so genauen
wettervorhersagen man konnte sich nicht
auf hurricanes vorbereiten deswegen
starben auf den keys viele hunderte
menschen durch sie
während der bauarbeiten wurden die
brücken von drei schweren hurricanes
erschüttert mehr als 100 arbeiter kamen
ums leben und das gesamte projekt stand
auf der kippe
aber nach drei jahren war es geschafft
lieber hier 100 bridge erstreckte sich
1500 40 meter weit bis zur nächsten
insel
doch wurde der rest der bahnstrecke
ebenfalls rechtzeitig fertig
[Musik]
es war schwierig die brücken zu bauen
die gegend war zum großen teil noch
unerschlossen es gab moskitos und andere
insekten es war sehr heiß und alles an
trinkwasser und nahrung musste her
geschafft werden außerdem noch die
baumaterialien
1912 waren die barrieren der bridge und
die gesamte strecke der overseas the
world schließlich fertig und befahrbar
zwei jahre folger als der panamakanal
jeder technik interessierte mensch auf
erden kannte damals den panamakanal als
beeindruckendes bauwerk des planeten
aber für viele mag diese
eisenbahnstrecke auf einem knappen
zweiten platz
und ging der plan auf
entstand hier das tor zu den usa
leider erfüllte sich der traum vom
handelsverkehr durch den panamakanal
nicht die schiffe fuhren einfach an key
west vorbei zu den großen häfen an der
ostküste oder in richtung texas und new
orleans
dadurch kam also kein geld ein aber
immerhin kamen touristen so nach key
west lüftern der labour day hurricane
von 1935 zuschlug
mehr als 200 wurden arbeiter kamen bei
dem unwetter ums leben
insgesamt starben auf dem kies mehr als
400 menschen durch den hurrikan
neben den todesfällen verursachte er
außerdem einen millionenschaden an der
overseas the world und das unternehmen
konnte die nötigen reparaturen nicht
bezahlen
sie verkauften das ganze mit allem drum
und dran an den start der sowieso schon
an einem highway baute die alten brücken
wurden umgebaut und für autos befahrbar
gemacht
in den 1970 er jahren entstand neben der
bar honda bridge eine neue vierspurige
brücke ein stück der alten brücke wurde
entfernt damit schiffe durchfahren
konnten
letztlich wurde sie ganz dem verfall
überlassen
heute sind die zwei teile der bahia
honda bridge die sichtbarsten
erinnerungen an ein außergewöhnliches
projekt aber es finden sich auch noch
kleinere andenken
vor ein paar wochen fand ich am strand
diesen schienen nagel er ist über 100
jahre alt man sieht noch die spuren der
hammerschläge hier oben das führt einem
noch einmal vor augen wie hart die
männer damals in der prallen sonne
gearbeitet haben dieser nagel erzählt
eine ganz eigene geschichte
[Musik]
tausende kilometer von florida entfernt
steht in der ostsee vor der küste polens
eine rätselhafte anlage
gut 300 meter vom land entfernt ragt
dieser verfallende betonbau aus dem
wasser empor
mit dem aussichtsturm und der isolierten
lage sieht es aus wie ein
hochsicherheitsgefängnis oder das
hauptquartier eines james bond
bösewichts
der turm ist etwas seltsam man fragt
sich ob es eine art leuchtturm oder
meeres forschungseinrichtung war es sind
nur die überreste einer wohl einst viel
größeren eindrucksvolleren anlage
und was oberhalb der wasserlinie zu
sehen ist erzählt nur einen teil der
geschichte
in der nähe liegt ein versunkener steg
da fragt man sich ob er mal dazugehört
hat dieser ort birgt viele rätsel und
wirft viele fragen auf
wozu also diente diese anlage und warum
wurde die verbindung zum land gekappt so
dass sie nun verlassen im meer steht
die antwort geht auf ein ns waffen
forschungsprogramm während des zweiten
weltkriegs zurück
[Gelächter]
eines der wichtigsten waffensysteme
während des zweiten weltkriegs war der
torpedo die von deutschen u boot
abgefeuerten torpedos hatten das
potenzial den krieg massiv zugunsten der
nazis zu beeinflussen
torpedos können ein kriegsschiff zwar
beschädigen aber normalerweise nicht
versenken ungepanzerte handelsschiffe
sind für sie jedoch leichte beute im
kampf um die vorherrschaft im atlantik
terrorisierten deutsche u-boot verbände
mit ihrer rudel taktik die
handelsflotten der alliierten
[Musik]
für die kriegswirtschaft briten waren
die konvois über den atlantik
unverzichtbar die sogenannte atlantik
schlacht war eine entscheidende und eine
der längsten des ganzen zweiten
weltkriegs
insgesamt verloren die alliierten 3500
handels und 175 kriegsschiffe mehr als
72.000 alliierte seeleute wurden getötet
[Musik]
vor allem ein mann wird mit der
deutschen rodel- taktik assoziiert
admiral karl dönitz ab 1939
oberbefehlshaber der u boote er setzte
sie als vernichtende waffen ein
aber die torpedos der unterseeboote
waren nicht immer zuverlässig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zu beginn des krieges explodierten 30
prozent der torpedos nicht wann sie
sollten
das problem an den deutschen torpedos
waren die abstands zünder sie wurden vom
magnetfeld der erde gestört so dass sie
oft weit vor ihrem ziel detonierten
da war also eigentlich eine menge
grundlagenforschung nötig aber bei
kriegsbeginn 1939 hatte deutschland sie
noch nicht erledigt
den deutschen befehlshabern war klar
dass die torpedo technologie schleunigst
verbessert werden musste in dieser
anlage sollte zur lösung des problems
geforscht werden der torpedo waffenplatz
hexen grund in der damals deutsch
besetzten danziger bucht
[Musik]
taucher mario schimanski kennt sich hier
gut aus
2001 tauchte ich das erste mal an der
torpedo testanlage sie war immer
geheimnisumwoben es ist nicht so ohne
hierzu tauchen denn im wasser lauern so
einige gefahren zum beispiel teile von
torpedos und andere dinge
in polen ist der bau heute als top it
dorf näher bekannt aber was hier noch zu
sehen ist war nur ein kleiner teil des
gesamtkomplexes
an land gab es unter anderem einen
fliegerhorst fertigungsanlagen und einem
rangierbahnhof
rund 2500 menschen arbeiteten auf der
gesamten torpedo testanlage
[Musik]
es gab einstiegsstellen für taucher
hilfen für kleine schiffe
forschungseinrichtungen werkstätten und
unterkünfte für die bediensteten
die anlage im wasser war mit alldem über
einen langen pier verbunden über den die
neuen torpedos heran transportiert
wurden
er führte zu diesem u förmigen gebäude
das dazu diente die torpedos abzufeuern
die vor ort gefertigt worden waren
torpedo villa spielte eine sehr wichtige
rolle
so wollte sich die deutsche kriegsmarine
den entscheidenden vorteil in der
atlantic schlacht verschaffen aber warum
haben die deutschen die testanlage in
der bucht von danzig gebaut weitab der
eigentlichen schlacht
[Musik]
die torpedo testanlage wurde 1940
eingerichtet und 1942 in betrieb
genommen die deutschen wählten bewusst
einen abgelegenen ort an dem keine
luftangriffe der alliierten zu
befürchten waren
dieses forschungs und
entwicklungszentrum musste geschützt
werden denn es war sehr wichtig für den
bau von torpedo prototypen
[Musik]
aber diese torpedos werden nicht für den
u boot einsatz bestimmt der hexen grund
wurde von der luftwaffe betrieben die
waffen sollten also per flugzeug
eingesetzt werden
mehrere länder hatten bereits wirksame
luft torpedos darunter auch japan dessen
streitkräfte ihre zerstörerische kraft
1941 bei dem angriff auf die us flotte
in pearl harbor unter beweis gestellt
hatten
[Musik]
deutschland hängte auf diesem gebiet
hinterher
in den frühen kriegsjahren verpasst
deutschland vor allem in der schlacht
bei norwegen die gelegenheit britische
kriegsschiffe anzugreifen und der
britischen flotte verluste beizubringen
den deutschen fehlt ein wirkungsvoller
luft torpedo
die ns-führung erwartete schnelle
ergebnisse und hier sollten sie erzielt
werden
aber luft torpedos zu entwickeln brachte
eine reihe völlig neuer schwierigkeiten
mit sich
torpedos sind sehr empfindlich ist schon
schwer genug sie von einem u boot oder
schiff aus abzufeuern sie aus der luft
abzuwerfen ist etwas völlig anderes
man braucht irgend eine vorrichtung um
sie gesteuert abwerfen zu können so dass
sie beim wechsel vom medium luft ins
medium wasser nicht außer kontrolle
geraten
auf den ersten blick scheint wenig
darauf hinzudeuten dass es der luftwaffe
hier je gelang schlagkräftige torpedos
zu entwickeln aber die ostsee gibt
manchmal einige geheimnisse der anlage
preis
das hier ist ein äußerst seltenes objekt
es handelt sich um eine taufe richtung
die am sprengkopf des torpedos
angebracht war das ist wahrscheinlich
der einzige noch existierende prototyp
weltweit
aber nicht nur diese hülle hat
überdauert auch einige komplexere
komponenten sind in erstaunlich gutem
zustand erhalten
das ist das kreiselinstrument es
funktioniert auch noch wie man sieht es
kontrollierte die bahn des torpedos wie
eine art computer von kreiselinstrument
hing alles ab es war das wichtigste
steuerungselement des torpedos
hier wurden die neuen torpedo prototypen
getestet die ingenieure beobachteten die
versuche vom turm aus
der torpedo wurde von einer rampe aus in
einen unterwasser abschuss schacht
eingelegt
dann schoss man ihn in einem elf
kilometer langen kanal durch die bucht
[Musik]
zum schluss wurden sie mit torpedo
netzen abgefangen auf kleinen boden
brachte mandant euro aus die die
torpedos wagen und schließen wurden
gegebenenfalls anpassungen vorgenommen
und die torpedos dann erneut getestet
bei weiteren tests war von flugzeuge
torpedos in der wucht ab
aber letztlich gelang es der luftwaffe
nicht zu anderen nationen aufzuschließen
in der schlacht wurden aus anfänglichen
erfolgen bald enorme verluste als die
alliierten immer besser darin wurden
tiefliegende torpedo bomber abzuschießen
hätten sie die luft torpedos schon
früher im krieg gehabt hätte dass zb im
mittelmeer enorme auswirkungen haben
können aber dazu kam es nicht
die hexen grund hätte eine große rolle
spielen können hat er aber nicht die
anlage funktionierte zwar aber man hatte
einfach viel zu spät mit der forschung
begonnen
sie waren einfach zu spät dran es gelang
nicht mehr die torpedo technik
rechtzeitig zu perfektionieren
die nazis hatten gehofft am hexen und
einen entscheidenden vorteil im atlantik
krieg erzielen zu können aber daraus
wurde nichts
mit dem vormarsch der roten armee wurde
die anlage schließlich aufgegeben
heute stehen nur noch überreste des
buchs förmigen gebäudes die vordere wand
ist schon vor jahren ins meer gestürzt
wie lange dieses denkmal des scheiterns
noch sichtbar sein wird ist fraglich
[Musik]
es erinnert daran wie viel von
technischem fortschritt abhängig ist wer
sich nicht schnell genug
weiterentwickelt wird scheitern so wie
es den deutschen mit ihren torpedos
ergangen ist
[Musik]
im meer um die verklemmt inseln im
südatlantik bietet sich ein seltsamer
anblick ein verlassenes segelschiff
gestrandet auf einer sandbank
da liegt dieses rostige wrack in der
bucht woher kommt es kampf
bei einem werk denkt man meist an ein
völlig kaputtes schiff aber dieses wird
noch ziemlich intakt woraus besteht es
warum zerfällt es nicht
man fragt sich was damit los ist es in
kaum grosse schäden zu sehen es wirkt
fast als könne man segel setzen und
direkt aus dem hafen hinaus fahren
das schiff hält sich wacker auf recht
als habe es sowohl der zeit als auch den
elementen getrotzt
es hat etwas gruseliges an sich man
fragt sich was dahinter steckt was es
mit diesem relikt vergangener zeiten auf
sich hat dass er auch seine crew zu
warten scheint
warum ist es in diesem beklagenswerten
zustand
wurde es im krieg angegriffen haben
piraten gekapert und dann einfach dort
zurückgelassen oder hat die crew
gemeutert
was ist mit diesem schiff passiert und
warum ist es ausgerechnet in dieser
abgelegenen gegend gestrandet
[Musik]
die geschichte beginnt auf der anderen
seite des atlantiks in der zweiten
hälfte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts als
ein mächtiges reich die meere beherrscht
großbritannien
es war die zeit der industriellen
revolution
nur wenige jahrzehnte zuvor war die
textilindustrie der wichtigste teil der
britischen wirtschaft gewesen jetzt galt
großbritannien als werkstatt der welt
war ein industrielles machtzentrum dank
der neuen fabriken in den großen städten
zwei voraussetzungen waren unerlässlich
um die britische industrie am laufen zu
halten die schlagkräftigeren ev als
stärkste flotte der welt und das
britische weltreich
[Musik]
das britische weltreich als größtes
reich der geschichte basierte auf dem
handel sobald die industrielle
revolution eingesetzt hatte und
großbritannien sich nicht mehr selbst
versorgen konnte waren die briten darauf
angewiesen nahrung und rohstoffe aus dem
ausland einzuführen und ihre güter
weltweit zu exportieren und zu verkaufen
um die ganze fracht transportieren zu
können wurden dringend mehr und
billigere schiffe gebraucht sie war
eines davon die lady elizabeth
[Musik]
1879 ging sie auf jungfernfahrt aber
wozu ein dreimaster im zeitalter der
dampfmaschine
die antwort lautet kosten
ein segelschiff verbraucht keine teure
kohle der wind ist gratis man darf es
nur nicht eilig haben die ware kommt ja
auch mit einem segelschiff irgendwann
ans ziel
[Musik]
sie wirkt zwar altmodisch ist aber eher
ein modernes schiff das sieht man am
baumaterial ihr rumpf ist aus eisen mit
aus holz
eisen rechnet sich mehr als holz denn so
hat man mehr platz für die fracht und
das bedeutet dass die fahrten
profitabler sind
aber welches unglück führte dazu dass
dieses zuverlässige profitable schiff so
fern seiner heimat zurück gelassen wurde
[Musik]
das leben auf see war damals keine
vergnügungsfahrt mit die mannschaft der
lady elizabeth bereits 1884 zu spüren
bekam auf der überfahrt von london nach
sydney
als sie das kap hoorn umsegelt gerieten
sie in winder mit hurrikan-stärke
die das schiff schwer beschädigten die
crew kämpfte sie stundenlang ab um das
unwetter zu überstehen
sie mussten die masten an diesem hin und
her schaukelnden schiff hochklettern in
einem moment baumelten sie links über
dem wasser im nächsten rechts oft fielen
die seeleute aus der takelage direkt ins
wasser und umzukehren um sie zu retten
war absolut unmöglich
die lady elisabeth erreichte den
nächsten hafen aber für einige
crew-mitglieder war die überfahrt zu
viel gewesen sie kehrten delay die den
rücken und kamen nie wieder
einige jahre später dann verschwanden
zwei an malaria erkrankte seeleute auf
rätselhafte weise vom baum
[Musik]
plötzlich war einer der männer weg und
es sprach sich schnell an bord herum
dass er unauffindbar war das war schon
seltsam aber noch schlimmer wurde es als
am abend auch noch der zweite mann
verschwand
beinahe brach panik aus die crew prüfte
die rettungsboote die waren alle noch da
es war völlig ruhig gesehen
bis heute weiß man nicht was mit diesen
zwei männern passiert ist
aber was ist diesem schiff zugestoßen
das mysteriöse tragödien und schwerste
sie überstanden hat warum ist es hier an
den falklandinseln gestrandet
das ende der lady elizabeth kam 1913
ihre letzte fahrt führte sie mit einer
ladung holz auf die lange reise von
vancouver bis in den süden afrikas
wieder kam sie in schwere see das schiff
wurde stark beschädigt und vier mann
wurden im unwetter vor kap hoorn über
bord gespült
die schäden am schiff war und so groß
dass der kapitän beschloss den nächsten
hafen anzulaufen
die seeleute kämpften im unwetter um ihr
leben aber es sollte noch schlimmer
kommen
auf dem weg zum hafen rammte die lady
elisabeth einen felsen
[Musik]
sie steuerten einen kleinen hafen auf
den falklandinseln im südatlantik an und
krachten auf dem weg dorthin in einen
felsen der ein großes loch in den rumpf
riss und das schiff lief voll wasser und
die lady elizabeth war schwer
leckgeschlagen voll wasser laufen
schaffte sie es gerade noch so in den
hafen damit waren ihre tage auf hoher
see vorbei sie wurde gepflegt verkauft
und als schwimmendes holzlager im hafen
festgemacht
aber wenn sie nicht mehr auf große fahrt
gingen wie kann sie dann an ihrem
jetzigen standort
am 17 februar 1936 tobte ein unwetter
über den falkland inseln und die lady
elizabeth wurde aus ihrer verankerung in
potsdam gerissen sie trieb in bangkok wo
sie auf eine sandbank lief und dort
kostet sie seitdem vor sich hin
das interessante und auch gruselige an
der lady elizabeth ist dass ihr eiserner
rumpf so intakt wirkt
wenn ein wrack fast 100 jahre im wasser
liegt sind meistens nur noch teile davon
übrig hier stehen sogar die masten noch
sie sieht aus als sei sie noch vor nicht
allzu langer zeit seetüchtig gewesen
[Musik]
heute erinnert das rostige werk der lady
elizabeth an die seeleute die ihr leben
ließen und an die gefahren auf hoher see
[Musik]
die moral von der geschichte der lady
elizabeth ist dass die seeleute damals
ein schwieriges gefährliches leben
führten das oft tragisch endete
es gab mal pläne ein schwimmendes museum
aus der lady lässt zu machen um an ihre
lange dienstjahre und jeder fahrten rund
um die welt zu erinnern
aber leider ist das an der finanzierung
gescheitert
[Musik]
heute sind sie verlassen sie zählten
einmal zu den fortschrittlichsten bauten
der welt
diese verfallenden konstruktionen sind
ein echo der vergangenheit sie erzählen
von krieg und schrecken aber auch vom
entdeckergeist und fortschritt von allem
wozu menschen fähig sind
[Musik]